i
[Música]
comenzó la cumbre de los líderes del g-7
en cornwall reino unido- la pandemia de
kobe 19 el cambio climático son los dos
grandes temas a tratar el día de hoy
la cita será hasta el domingo y se
espera el regreso del multilateralismo
de eeuu tras la era trump luego vendrá
una cumbre con bailén con la unión
europea y con vladimir putin
con el 100% de las actas electorales
procesadas y con el 99 puntos 50 y 100
por ciento de las actas contabilizadas
aún no hay ganador oficial de la
contienda presidencial en el perú el
candidato pedro castillo tiene una
estrecha ventaja con el 50 punto 17 por
ciento de los votos frente al 49 puntos
82 por ciento de su rival keiko fujimori
francia hará una reducción de la misión
militar marcan en la región africana del
sahel que es de 2014 combate a los
grupos extremistas y yihadistas en ese
territorio esto implicaría disminuirá
los 5.100 militares que actualmente
están en los países de esta región
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos con la
cumbre del g7 en cornwall en reino
unido- que durará hasta el domingo el
primer punto de la agenda poner fin a la
pandemia de koi 19 a nivel global por lo
que el presidente estadounidense llegó a
la reunión con una promesa previa la
donación de 500 millones de dosis de la
vacuna de facer a los países pobres una
iniciativa a la que espera que se sume
el resto de las potencias luego de este
encuentro badén permanecerá unos días en
territorio europeo para reunirse con la
otan y la unión europea y además el
presidente ruso vladimir putin vamos en
directo a worldwide con nuestra enviada
especial
luisa pulido luisa muy buenos días un
gusto saludarla la cumbre del g7 se
enfocará en gran medida encontrar
entonces alternativas para acabar con
esta pandemia que se puede esperar de
compromisos concretos
buenas tardes desde falmouth el g7 se
espera una esfuerzos para que los países
en desarrollo puedan recibir vacunas
contra el kobe 19 lo más rápido posible
se espera que de esta cumbre salga el
compromiso el anuncio de la donación de
un millón de vacunas para los países en
desarrollo ya se ha anunciado por parte
de eeuu la donación de medio billón de
vacunas y el reino unido donará 100
millones de dosis sin embargo este
billón sería insuficiente para lo que
requiere el mundo en este momento
estimaciones de la organización mundial
de la salud aseguran que se requieren
por lo menos 11 billones de vacunas para
inmunizar el 70 por ciento de la
población mundial así que este es el
llamado más urgente vacunas y rápido
luisa qué importancia tiene esta cumbre
del g7 en reino unido
mucha es la primera cara cara en dos
años se recupere entonces la magia del
contacto face to face cara a cara el
contacto personal es el debut
internacional de joe by day además hemos
visto la transformación en el tono la
recuperación de aliados será la última
cumbre de angela merkel en el poder la
canciller alemana que lleva 15 años en
su cargo y se despedirá este septiembre
pero además por la coyuntura que estamos
viviendo en la que se espera que las
grandes potencias puedan ayudar dar
ideas de cómo recuperar la economía
mundial y salir de esta crisis que ha
dejado el cubit 19 luisa le pregunto si
puede la armonía de la cumbre de verse
empañada por las tensiones entre el
reino unido y la unión europea tras el
éxito
podría el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón antes de llegar aquí a fall vota
como ha dicho que nada con el beksitas
era re negociable y es que la nueva
atención entre londres y bruselas se da
por el protocolo de irlanda del norte si
esa región de la que hemos escuchado
durante más de tres años con el break
sido esta región que es parte del reino
unido permanece con las reglas de la
unión europea su mercado único es decir
que para enviar algún producto desde
cualquier ciudad británica al propio
país
irlanda del norte resulta un trámite de
exportación lo que está creando caos y
en muchos casos que los productos
básicos alimenticios no estén llegando
por ejemplo a belfast la capital de
irlanda del norte que también está
poniendo en riesgo consideran algunos el
acuerdo de paz de 1998 que trajo paz
política a estas zonas
luisa gracias por toda la información
más adelante volvemos con usted para
todos los detalles de esta cumbre del g7
y para analizar este tema nos acompaña
andrés servín doctor en ciencias
políticas en la lista internacional
presidente
sin presión al price autor de eurasia y
américa latina en un mundo multipolar
gracias andrés por acompañarnos en esta
emisión de noticias en france 24 es el
primer viaje al extranjero del
presidente de eeuu y lo hace para
asistir a esta cumbre del g7 que
significa esta visita después de la
sombra que dejó el expresidente donald
trump speed en un alivio
bueno bardem es fundamentalmente está en
un esfuerzo de restaurar las relaciones
con los aliados altamente deterioradas
por la administración de trump y
relanzar el multilateralismo como una
manera de poder generar una gobernanza
global que restaure el liderazgo de eeuu
a nivel internacional y en ese sentido
la cumbre de los países más
industrializados del g7 es fundamental
porque es cómo replantear el
multilateralismo de amigos que requiere
estados unidos para relanzar su
presencia protagónica en el sistema
internacional
ahora aprovechando la visita a bruselas
de bailén para reunirse con la otan el
próximo 14 de junio la unión europea
también tendrá reunión con el mandatario
estadounidense cuál es la importancia de
la restauración de estas relaciones con
el bloque que en la política exterior
estaban deterioradas por el aire a trump
pero fundamentalmente la importancia
está relacionada con que el mundo ha
vivido una transformación muy
significativa se han profundizando una
serie de tendencias que minan la
importancia del multilateralismo que
afectan la gobernanza global y desde
luego que impactan también en el proceso
de globalización con toda una serie de
planteamientos en torno a las carreras
suministros y en ese sentido está muy
claro que la aspiración de la
administración bailén es reconstituir
las alianzas y los vínculos positivos
con aquellas aquellos países que en
especial representan distintas formas de
democracia occidental entonces
evidentemente también en la visita
la participación en imágenes en el g7 la
participación la reunión de la otan
tienen implicaciones muy claras en
relación con lo que la administración de
eeuu considera las principales amenazas
a su seguridad y son que son china y
rúsia por lo tanto la consecuencia
digamos la frutilla del postre es el
proceso de este viaje es la reunión con
putin y un intento de estabilizar las
relaciones entre eeuu bloque occidental
en general y rusia en un marco en donde
rusia y china- se acercan cada vez más y
constituyen a su vez una alternativa en
el sistema internacional andrés
rápidamente tocaba un punto muy
importante y es la reunión que se espera
entonces del presidente de bailén con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin que puede
salir de esta reunión
bueno ninguno de los dos presidentes
tienen grandes expectativas en términos
de los avances de esta reunión los dos
lo han expresado muy claramente pero lo
más importante es que la reunión cede en
primer lugar porque restablece un canal
de comunicación directo entre los dos
presidentes y muy deterioradas en este
momento y en segundo lugar permite
analizar una agenda en donde hay una
serie de temas que son de carácter común
que interesan a los dos países que más
que nada se relacionan con la agenda
global tanto lo que tiene que ver con la
lucha contra una pandemia como los temas
de cambio climático los temas de lucha
contra el terrorismo
y la estabilización estratégica esto es
muy importante considerando que ambos
han firmado la continuidad del tratado
de estar a necesitar tres entonces estos
temas son los temas más preponderantes
yo diría dentro de la agenda de la
reunión y hay otros temas muy puntuales
que tienen que ver con las tensiones y
conflictos regionales que se dan entre
ambos países andrés gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
francés 24 horas pero cinco días después
de las elecciones presidenciales aún no
se conoce un grado oficial aunque el
líder del partido perú libre el profesor
pedro castillo lidera la contienda
mientras keiko fujimori se muestra poco
dispuesta a asumir el resultado la
oficina nacional de procesos electorales
la onpe ingresó al 100% de las actas de
votación y tiene el 99 puntos 56 por
ciento de las actas contabilizadas hasta
este momento el candidato izquierdista
pedro castillo tiene 50 puntos 17 por
ciento de los votos válidos con una
ventaja de 68 mil 473 votos frente a la
postulante derechista keiko fujimori
el 49.82 por ciento de sufragios
y es que mientras no se define un
ganador de estas elecciones
presidenciales en el perú el fiscal
anticorrupción de ese país pidió prisión
preventiva para la candidata derecha
keiko fujimori sumado a la atención a
este reñido proceso electoral hecho
calificado por keiko como absurdo alva
santana nos amplía esta información
a la atención electoral de perú que
cuenta con impugnaciones de actas y
acusaciones de fraude se le ha sumado un
nuevo factor dramático el fiscal
anticorrupción ha pedido prisión
preventiva para keiko fujimori la
candidata de extrema derecha con varias
causas abiertas en su contra en 2020
fujimori consiguió la libertad
condicional pero ahora el fiscal josé
domingo pérez pide que vuelva a la
cárcel por incumplimiento de las reglas
de conducta algo que la política niega
así que yo voy a seguir con mis
responsabilidades sin distraer este tipo
de pedidos a todos contrarios sin
sustentos fujimori está acusada por
varios delitos lavado de activos crimen
organizado y obstrucción a la justicia
todo a raíz de la financiación irregular
de sus campañas de 2011 y 2016 en las
que habría recibido hasta 36 millones de
dólares en donaciones de empresas como
la constructora brasileña odebrecht el
marzo pasado el fiscal pérez pidió una
pena de más de 30 años pero en abril de
te fue puesta en libertad condicional
por riesgo de contraer cobit 19 no
obstante una de las condiciones de su
libertad era no reunirse con testigos
del caso abierto algo que fujimori
habría incumplido al respecto su
adversario por la presidencia el
izquierdista pedro castillo aseguró que
el pedido judicial es algo secundario
para él
y vamos
el caso que enfrenta no ha impedido que
fujimori se presente a los comicios pero
la causa seguirá abierta a no ser que la
conservadora se convierta en presidenta
y consiga la inmunidad judicial
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
anunció una reducción de las tropas
francesas de malí donde en colaboración
con los militares de ese país le hacen
frente a la amenaza de las milicias
islamistas esto implicaría disminuir a
los 5.100 militares que actualmente
están en los países del sahel repasamos
la cronología de esta intervención
militar internacional en el país
africano
francia inició la intervención militar
en mali en enero de 2013 a petición del
entonces presidente john conde traure
cuando una ofensiva yihadista amenazaba
la capital del país bamako se solicite
solicite y obtuve el apoyo aéreo de
francia en el marco de la legalidad
internacional e internacional
mal y su pueblo no están solos en esta
lucha contra el terrorismo con decenas
de ataques aéreos el ejército francés se
embarcó entonces en la operación serbal
en mali en cuestión de semanas las
principales ciudades del norte del país
quedaron liberadas sin embargo la
operación duró año y medio hasta agosto
de 2014 cuando el operativo militar
francés se transformó porque la amenaza
terrorista persistía entraron en la
cooperación militar países del sahel
como mauritania níger y chad y la misión
de naciones unidas minustah la
intervención pasó a llamarse operación
marcan en total 5 mil 100 soldados
franceses y 8000 malienses han combatido
en el operativo con la presencia de
15.000 miembros de naciones unidas con
el objetivo oficial de privar a los
militantes islamistas de acceder a
medios de combate de comunicación y de
aprovisionamiento en el trópico
es utópico pensar que llegaremos a parar
todos los flujos para al menos impedir
este paso y mostrar que estamos activos
en la frontera ya son buenos
desde el inicio de la intervención 51
soldados franceses han perdido la vida
en mali mientras que la cifra de
malienses muertos a manos del ejército
de francia no es clara según naciones
unidas un bombardeo de la aviación
francesa mató al menos a 19 civiles que
celebraban una boda a principios de este
2021 ocho años después de intervenir
francia suspenderá la misión según
anunció este jueves el presidente
francés emmanuel macon y así llegamos al
final del informativo continuar con
nosotros
[Música]